so so bitcoin was kind of sort of the
original one but bitcoin is quite
limited in what it can do ethereum is uh
substantially more flexible and
programmable um but has serious
limitations around scaling and some
other things
um solana is kind of an attempt at
bringing
the last 20 years of of computers high
performance computer science and
distributed systems to a layer one
blockchain
um
and and the second thing that struck me
about i remember my conversation with
anatoly is he's like all i've done in my
whole career is make things go fast he's
like worked at at qualcomm at dropbox at
mesosphere a few other places and did
that and he
was not academic at all um
and was just like i make things go fast
and uh
that struck us as like yeah
these distributed systems
like those problems in computer science
have been understood for quite some time
um and here's a guy who has been
building various distributed systems for
for 10 15 years and really understands
them
and it's just applying kind of this new
crypto economic paradigm on top of that
right um and and uh that struck us as
like a very differentiated kind of
founder
and we had anatoly on recently episode
1302 for those of you who want to hear
from him from solana's uh ceo
you guys then participate in solana's
initial coin offering or their initial
token offering not sure what the term of
art is today uh i guess coin has been uh
is not used because icos were kind of uh
have a negative spin to them but these
uh tokens are released you buy them for
four cents
and you buy
a hundred thousand of them or a hundred
thousand dollars worth or two hundred
fifty thousand dollars worth
you know i don't remember how much we
bought in the initial token sale which
was in may of 18.
um they did a subsequent round in august
of 18
um which we led and then uh in the
company or in the tokens we all the
solana labs has never sold equity it's
so all all uh we're just token sales got
it um we led around in august of 18 in
early 19 after the market crashed at the
end of 18 a bunch of investors uh wanted
to sell and get out we bought out a
whole bunch of those investors
we led another round in june of 19
uh and then bought out more investors
after the token launched in april of 20.
wow um so we've been accumulating sole
across various entities at various
prices from four to
four cents to a dollar twenty
um and we've been buying more recently
in the public markets as well
and
then uh you
are buying these it's a
token but it's kind of a security you
then i guess get to distribute them to
your
lp's and your fund like i would in lp
and the launch funds and then they can
sell them if they want to if they can
find a buyer and then uh
lock in a reward without ever having
bought into uh c corporation a delaware
c corp correct
um i'll agree with most of that other
than i'm not sure i'm gonna call solana
security but directionally everything
else you described i would say is
accurate right so how does one determine
well it kind of acts like a security in
terms of the lps right they have this
asset that's gone up in value so i guess
that's one of the big questions here um
and uh
so then they get you get you distribute
them and they get to sell them and get a
gain if they want
do you how do you take
how do you have custodianship of all of
these and make sure that you don't get
to act or something horrible doesn't
happen and then when you distribute do
you actually
send somebody's wallet a bunch of soul
uh or do they have like a custodian and
then how do you mechanically make sure
that this stuff is safe
yeah so i don't know that's a stupid
question or a really important question
because we don't have this question in
startup investing because it's just a
cat table and some cfo somewhere will
you know make a change in it and it's
all paperwork et cetera this stuff just
moves
on so lana is really fast
um i actually think it's funny you made
that last comment about the cfo because
even in that there's a lot of trust
involved sure um in that system and it's
like who kept all the pdfs and like made
sure the excel document got updated
correctly yeah um wilson cincini
a bunch of law firms who could pay 1200
an hour
yeah generally a good theory rule of
thumb is if you can unbundle a function
of a law firm and turn it into software
that's usually a good good business to
be in yeah they like they like doing
that too yeah
um but yeah so look when we started it
was it was a lot worse we self-custody
it's a lot of stuff back in the day
today if you read our lpas
our lpas do say we can self-custody
because whenever new assets are created
sometimes there isn't an institutional
custodian provider at the time of the
network launch so from time to time we
do have to take self-custody and there's
a whole set of processes we do around
that um but at this point you know 98 99
of our firm's assets are custodied with
uh primarily with coinbase custody um as
well as with bitgo and copper who are
institutional sec qualified custodians
so those custodians will hold yourself
and to charge you one percent of the
assets a year or something i heard or 50
basis points it's much lower than that i
i'm not sure i'm allowed to disclose
their pricing but it's
one percent would be extremely high so
it acts just like a venture firm except
these tokens can be used in the real
world
so you explain the framework before you
have people who are working on the
project you have speculators investors
uh and then you have people who use the
tokens is that right those are the
general
uh constituents in these groups
i think that's about approximately
correct yeah
and so
uh with solana specifically what it was
the value what's the value proposition
because it's not nasdaq for blockchain
right now it's something else
what is it today or did they actually
meet that uh original vision and why has
it all of a sudden become one of the top
six or seven crypto projects what was
unique about this one
yeah so um
again the anatomy's original vision was
i want to run an order book on chain
this is
well before d5 was even a term
um
d5 as a term was coined in about october
or november of 9 of 18. um and anatoly
kind of understood that blockchains are
financial engines primarily first and
foremost and that you should design a
system from the ground up to enable
price price discovery is the
foundational function of capital markets
and the way you have price discovery is
you have an order book obviously this is
what nasdaq and nazi and plenty of other
people do
um so that was the goal from day one the
solana blockchain launched on april of
20 about a year and a half ago
and uh conveniently right around the
same time a guy named sam bankman freed
who's the ceo of ftx started to get real
excited about d5 um and and realizing it
was going to change his his ftx business
um as a centralized exchange started
hacking around on ethereum was extremely
unhappy with performance of the system
and looked elsewhere and ended up
picking solana to kind of uh go all in
on uh for two reasons primarily one was
um the the under the understanding the
importance of the order book as the
fundamental technical primitive that
underlies all the finance and two the
focus on intra-shard scaling as opposed
to inter-shard scaling which is more or
less what everyone else has focused on
in crypto other than solana um
and uh that led him to build this thing
called serum
on top of uh solana which is a
decentralized exchange and an order book
um on the slanted blockchain
um and that kind of hat launched in
august of last year
and since then uh that's kind of sparked
a real growth in a d5 ecosystem around
solana and which is then led into nfts
and all kinds of other really
interesting
things
micro acquire is a startup acquisition
marketplace that cuts out the middleman
basically that means they help startups
get acquired efficiently if you're a
founder looking to sell
acquire is free private and involves no
middlemen you know how it is you try to
get a deal going there's somebody in the
middle they don't care about the parties
involved in some cases they just want to
close a deal and you really have to
wonder who are they working for right
you're always wondering about incentives
there well you don't have to worry about
incentives at micro acquire to date
micro acquire has helped hundreds of
startups get acquired and they
facilitated hundreds of millions in
closed deal volume their platform
includes over a hundred thousand buyers
including me i'm paying for the service
it's pretty great there are thousands of
startups currently listed for sale and
hundreds of successful acquisitions have
occurred so far founders get free and
instant access to over 100 000 trusted
buyers while staying totally anonymous
on the other side of the marketplace
buyers like me simply play 290 a year
for access to deals on the platform
which means
you're getting rid of the look you lose
right unless you're serious about this
you're not going to pay the 290 so micro
acquire help startups find buyers it's
as simple as that they'll help you start
conversations that can lead to an
acquisition in just 30 days for free
just go to
dot com slash try.microacquire.com
once again try.microacquire.com
twist